here we are at the fujitsu booth
checking out the arrows tablet it has a
10.1 inch 1280 x 800 screen and it's 4g
LTE here's some of the things it has
inside it's got a 1 gigahertz dual-core
TI omap processor on the back it's got a
5.1 megapixel camera and on the front it
has a 1.3 megapixel camera it runs
Android Gingerbread it has a textured
plastic rim that makes it easy to hold
on the back towards the top is a power
button and also a volume rocker but the
coolest thing is that it's waterproof so
if you drop it in the bathtub or the
toilet you don't have to worry about it
its water proof for up to five feet for
up to 30 minutes it's currently
available in Japan and we're not sure
when it's coming to the US